let's take some phone calls the number
is 6 1 7 8 30 for 750 we are not pre
screening for topics you could basically
asked whatever's on your mind I believe
we have our first caller here who's on
the line where you calling from and of
course most importantly of what could we
answer for you today uh Tyler from New
Jersey Tyler great to hear from you
what's on your mind the other day while
answering a question you mentioned you
were in a band before I was just curious
uh what kind of is rated to play in what
kind use it was a band how long did you
do that for yes I was in a couple bands
years and years ago when i was in
western Massachusetts I was in a band
called down on elm it was in alternative
rock band uh former producer Louis was
in that band I played drums and Louis
played uh sometimes guitar sometimes
base he would switch off more recently
when i was living in new york city in
brooklyn i was in a band called ten
fingers not ten fingers but tensor like
the Tin Man in Wizard of Oz and it was
also an alternative rock band we played
a handful of shows before two of us
moved out of New York I moved out of New
York and will and one of the guitar /
bassists also moved out in New York and
that was the end of my band career I've
been sort of looking a little bit here
in Boston but they haven't found
anything yet you know it's tough welcome
all right well thank you so much for the
call that was a very concrete question
some questions require that I sort of uh
uh you know speculate in different ways
very concrete and absolutely nothing
wrong with that